does that not have an effect on how you
think about about it not really okay not
really but
um I think we should be friends first of
all
we should get support for each other
we should be equal
think that's important you think men and
women can be equal
there's an intruder coming into the
house are you guys equally gonna fight
him no yes
I'm gonna run and call the police
you deal with him so no so no okay
anything else oh no you said you don't
know no okay but you want it to be equal
So when you say equal do you mean equal
set because a lot of girls say that and
I'm like I don't really know what they
mean by that like they want a partner
equal
I think it's about support
and how you understand each other and
when someone have a bad day you just
have to be there for them and push them
up don't push them down
I think that's important
but what does that have to do with being
equal
I mean like I know we shouldn't push
each other down but what is that
I don't know
you mean like your views are equal kind
of thing yeah like he respects you you
respect him like the discipline between
us like all the respect he shouldn't
tell you what to do and you don't tell
him what to do kind of thing you just
mutually agree we should yeah we should
have a conversation about everything and
just agree yeah but what about when you
disagree what happens we will find a way
then where are you gonna listen if he
says
I'm gonna say I'm wrong if I'm wrong I'm
wrong yeah but then so then you wouldn't
be equal right
if if if you guys disagree and then you
have to trust him to make a decision
well
I think she just means that she doesn't
want to like a dictatorship type of
relationships yeah we need to agree we
need to have the conversation we need to
talk about our problems see I don't I
don't think you realize how this sounds
to man
and I I used to say something similar so
I'm not judging you but when you're like
oh we need to talk about our problems
and talk about every issue and like
until we don't really want to lose no
they just wanted they don't want to like
they just want they just want a girl to
listen yeah okay we're gonna do this and
then she says but why do we do it but
why like men hate that but why it's like
a tree like they hate it yeah that's
true yeah right
but I was just curious
um how you expected that to go because
when girls say equal I don't know if
they'd actually want a guy because when
I hear equal it's it just sounds like
girls want a guy that like follows what
they want
I feel like it works more like an
equilibrium rather than equalness
because more of a wave it kind of goes
it is a wave yeah rather but I think
equality maybe is the wrong tone to be
using more of an equilibrium is right
and because it goes back and forth and
it's never a straight line to have
equalness is where you will have
problems to say that you're equal isn't
right because you won't work as a
relationship if you're both equal
I'm curious just show of hands and then
I'll go to your I'm just curious
who here would submit to their husband's
Authority
I will you would okay so it wouldn't be
equal then yeah but he'd be above you no
yeah just to submit you you do need to
be willing to back down and not be equal
anymore
okay so so you say you would though you
would submit well I
oh it's a tricky one
maybe not okay no I would you would okay
is that what you do now in your
relationship he makes all the decisions
um no
is that just gonna change when you guys
get married or what
if he's a provider yes so if he he pays
all the bills he can decide everything
he's my boss okay uh what about you
you said you would
uh to some extent yeah what do you mean
um I don't know like what it feels
tricky yeah
I'd say to some extent well I think
either way women like well anyway it's
about me so
um if I was a wife I'd I like
the leadership role on his end okay you
know but when it comes to
I think equality is the wrong word but
decision making I like to be part of it
or
um who respects me enough to be like oh
babe you know and uh discuss about
certain things but I would respect his
word for things but
I think
I think just being on a general level
that we respect each other on certain
things or most things just to keep it
leveled and to make it work then it's
like oh no I've got this power over you
or it's like me arguing back you know
that makes sense but answering your
question at the start
um are like a partner in crime and a
best friend I think everyone thrives
um
to get that do you think that's normal
in history that men and women were best
friends
I think mine was the question no the man
yeah the head of the family oh yeah when
do you think that's switched
probably with this generation I don't
know was it like the 1970s or something
do you think that has good outcomes
being best friends with your husband
um
who said yes yeah yeah who who said yes
you did you did
then why are we more divorced than ever
before but maybe that's where my point
comes in of not wanting to get married
so if you're really gonna want to get
married I'm like you have to be friends
with them whether you like it or not
this is the right crowd to be talking in
this channel well she makes it you make
a very good point because because where
all of this is going it's kind of what I
was trying to say to articulate the
beginning which is that is the marriage
certificate fit for purpose anymore
given we've got all these Dynamics going
on in society given there's all these
Divergent wants and needs and people
trying to wiggle out of you know not
wanting to be submit or whatever does it
actually work anymore I'm not convinced
that it does work anymore and I think
the reason it works for you know for
better or worse and there's arguments in
both cases but the reason it worked
before was because society and religion
kept it in place and there were certain
expectations for what you did and now
those expectations aren't there so
everyone goes and says the lines that
pull right out in the church but nobody
really means it and then 10 years later
they're just like oh so that you know
and that is not a good basis for for
marriage so do we need something else or
do we I mean you know there's a personal
choice here as well I haven't chosen to
get married up to this point largely
because of this stuff you know to be
honest
um or maybe you just haven't met the
right woman well the yeah I mean who
makes you want to get married no I mean
look I mean I wouldn't I never rule
anything out entirely but like I said
I'm not I'm not championing at the bits
oh my God I really want to get married I
really want to sign up to this contract
where I can get half of my stuff taken
away on a whim I mean it's just not do
you know what I mean like I'm happy
um being in sort of long-term
relationships or more casual
relationships whatever but marriage I
mean I mean would you sign a contract
where you only have a 10 chance of
getting your kids if he takes them
and he can take half your stuff
and the house and you'd have to move out
would you sign it
and you want to get one and a half meals
a day
I I think if
if their value was very high in my life
then I would take that risk I'm a risk
taker anyway and I feel like if I'm
gonna get something out of that which is
what I really want and which is what
I've always wanted in life which is love
and to be loved I'll take that risk
because that's the purpose of life to be
loved everybody here is searching to be
loved to be wanted and to be appreciated
by someone that is
sorry but I think everybody is searching
for that like everybody in the end just
wants to be loved or find that person
who accepts them for who they are but
why would you need marriage for that
yeah yeah
um you're still being around well for me
it's like I don't know it's like
religion and things like that like
that's something
another thing is you say except for for
who they are but what if it is the guy
who you are is somebody who wants to
sleep around every couple of weeks you
know and sort of have sex with the
Barista or the girl who's working the
nightclub do you know what I mean
because this is a whole other area
because obviously male sexuality is is
you know by and large you know they they
like Pearl said I think earlier you know
they want to have sex with as many
people as possible women have a slightly
different sort of agenda for the most
part
um and then you get into this whole area
where and I've seen other [__] you know
other podcasts where they talk about
this but like um
you know a guy can really truly love a
woman
um and still go and have sex with
somebody else and that's purely by
that's purely physical yeah and it
doesn't detract from his love from the
woman but but for many women you would
say well well tell me tell me about you
honestly what is it what is your your
makeup it's like well I like showing you
around I mean a lot of women are not
going to accept that you know what I
mean so but that's not that's not like
that's not like by force that's just
like a preference for a man that there
are men who can actually be uh loyal
like they can they can but come on it's
not it's just it's not like something
that's wrong with them or it's like this
is who they are like if most men were in
Tiger Woods position
that's like me saying well I want a
Hermes back you know well she said you
studied zoology didn't you have you got
any input on this I mean do you think
the males generally they look you know
they want to get their underwear I mean
men naturally in like if you look at the
other primates though yes so we are a
primate
um sorry to anyone that doesn't believe
in evolution but we are a primate and
other male primates like chimpanzees
will meet with several females and it's
the biological makeup is to breed
monogamous no and and I don't from
looking back in the evolution of
hominins which is what we are we're a
hominin
they weren't monogamous and it's not
necessarily the way we're made up it's
Society that's done that so for you to
say that someone should always be with
the same person for the rest of them
like their lives huh but if that's not
what they want then so be it don't judge
someone because that's what they're
saying but you know on the other side of
it you're but to get into cancer what I
just said you are right because if the
guy is also signing up for that marriage
contract then he should also abide by
that contract yeah do you know what I
mean but then it comes back to my
question which is well is it in the guys
is it in my best interest to sign up for
it then you know I do I hear your point
I really do and I do hear your point
like why would a man want to sign up for
that paper
um and I I really feel like it just
comes down to the individual and and
what they believe in and I feel like
yeah it is it is to do with religion
definitely I honestly think if most men
knew what they were signing I don't
think most men would do it and I think
if you took religion out of it as well
there's a lot of I know like a lot of
Muslim men you know they wouldn't get
married doing this documentary I just I
can't even believe like the stories I've
heard so they're crazy they're crazy
like guys get screwed over especially I
think it's worse here than the US really
can't shock him it depends on the
statements yeah yeah but I don't I don't
know enough about I've actually I've
learned more about the laws here than
the US now but
um I think we're gonna close out the
show so thank you guys all for coming um
we're gonna do final thoughts so any
final thoughts you want to say speak
your piece on um start here go around
Instagram social medias you want to
shout go ahead okay
um Instagram I think I said that in the
beginning but I'll just say again um
Kiki underscore chi on Instagram and I
do have a hair page as well
touched by Chi underscore
um but final thoughts
um
I would just say honestly get married if
you want to get married if you don't
want to get married no one's forcing you
don't get married it's it's it's as easy
as that
um and obviously like culture definitely
does player play A Part
um for example like I'm Nigerian so our
culture is very much get married then
have kids and this this that like
there's not really a I wouldn't say like
your career or like
career isn't really like a big thing
like as much as education is pushed onto
us to go and get that degree and
everything like that at the end of the
day
the end goal
um in my type of culture is to get
married is to have kids and it just
depends on the different cultures and
um when you have different cultures
you're going to have different
interpretations and different views and
everyone has different views that's fine
if you don't want to get mine that's
fine but yeah that's my last doors
um
yeah Instagram cicana TV
s-u-k-a-i-n-a-tv
um you can also find me on Tick Tock
cicana Louisa so yeah
um final thoughts as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible